Open sources self in,
in its title,
pretty much people kind
of understand what it is.
It means that various
coders get to share in this,
this code and the source code and they
they get to innovate and they all get to
participate and use each
other's work. Right, right. Um,
but blockchain is confusing for a lot
of people. Could you explain that?
Sure. I'm in Blah Blah. Blockchain
itself is almost a misnomer.
So we're confusing. Things are confusing
at, at the, at every level, right.
So we can,
we should start with the
idea of a distributed ledger,
which is basically like a distributed
excel spreadsheet or database.
It's just a store of information which
is not stored just in one place where
there's copies of it in a
lot of different places.
Every time my copy of it is updated,
everyone else's copy of it has, has,
has got to be updated.
And then then there's various bells and
whistles like sharding where you know,
it can be broken in many pieces and
each piece is stored many places or
something. So That's a distributed ledger
and that's just distributed computing.
Now what?
What makes it more interesting is when
you layered decentralized control onto
that.
So imagine you have this distributed
excel spreadsheet or distributed database.
There's copies of it stored in a
thousand places, but to update it,
you need like 500 of those thousand
people who own the copies to vote. Yeah,
let's do that update,
right?
So then then you have a distributed store
of data and you have like a democratic
voting mechanism to determine when all
those copies can get can get updated
together.
Right.
So then then what you have is a data
storage and update mechanism that's
controlled in a democratic way by the
group of participants rather than money
one central controller. And that that
can have all sorts of advantages.
I mean for one thing
it means that you know,
there's no one controller who can go
rogue and screw with other day without
telling anyone.
It also means there's no one who some
lewd taking go hold a gun to their head
and shoot them for for what data
updates from aid because the, you know,
it's controlled democratically
by bye everybody. Right.
It has ramifications in terms of,
you know,
legal defensibility and I mean you
could have some people in Iran,
some in China,
some in the u s and and updates to this
whole distributed data store are made by
democratic decision of all
the participants somewhere
cryptography comes in is
when I vote, I don't have to say, yeah,
this is Ben Goertzel voting for
this update to be accepted or not.
It's just ID number one,
three, five, seven, two, six,
four and then encryption is used
to make sure that, you know, it's,
it's the same guy voting every time that
it claims to be without needing like
your, your passport number or something.
Right. What's ironic about it,
it's probably one of the best ways
ever conceived to actually vote in this
country.
Yeah,
sure.
And it would be kind of ironic.
There's a lot of applications
for the [inaudible], right?
So there's so that,
I mean that's the core mechanism.
Now where the block chain comes from is
like a data structure where to store the
data in this distributed database,
it's stored in a chain of blocks
or each block contains data.
The thing is not every
so-called blockchain system
even uses a chain of blocks
and I would like some user,
a tree or a graph of blocks or something.
So that term,
I mean it's,
it's an all right term like AI,
like just one of those terms
were stuck with one of the,
it's one of those terms were stuck with,
even though it's not quite technically
not quite technically accurate.
I mean any more, I mean cause w w, W, W I
don't know another buzzword for it, right.
What it is is a,
it's a distributed ledger with
encryption and decentralized control and
blockchain is the buzzword that's
come about for that. Now, what,
what got me interested in blockchain
really is this decentralized control
aspect. So my, my wife, who
I've been with for 10 years now,
she dug up recently
something I'd forgotten,
which is a webpage and made
in 1995 like a long time ago,
where I'd said,
hey,
I'm going to run for president on the
decentralization platforms. Right.
Which I'd completely forgotten that,
that crazy idea. I was very young then.
I had no idea what an annoying job
being president would be. Right.
But the,
so that the idea of decentralized
control seem very important to me.
Back then, which is well before bitcoin
was invented because I could see,
you know, a global brain is evolving on
the planet involving humans, computers,
communication devices. And we don't want
this global brain to be controlled by,
by a small elite. We want the
global parent to be controlled in a,
in a decentralized way. So,
right. So that, that's really the,
the beauty of this a blockchain
infrastructure. And what,
what got me interested in the practical
technologies of blockchain was really
one etherium came out and you add
the notion of a smart contract,
which etherium yeah. So
what does that, well,
so the first blockchain
technology was Bitcoin, right?
Which is a well known cryptocurrency.
Now etherium is another cryptocurrency,
which is the number two cryptocurrency
right now. That's all a loop I am.
Did you know about it? He did. However,
ethereum came along with a
really nice software framework.
So it's not just like a
digital money like bitcoin is,
but it theory,
IOM has a programming language called
solidity that came with it and this
programming language, let's see, right,
where they're called smart contracts.
And again,
that sort of a misnomer because the
smart contract doesn't have to be either
smart or a contract, right? But
it was a cool name, right? Right.
Then if it's really a smart,
it's a chart.
It's like a programmable transaction.
Okay.
So you can program a legal contract
or you can program of a financial
transaction. So as a
smart contract, it's a,
it's a persistent piece of software
that embodies like a secure encrypted
transaction between,
between multiple parties.
So pretty much like anything on,
on the back end of a bank's website
or a transaction between two companies
online, a purchasing relationship,
which you and the website online.
This could all be scripted in the
smart contract in this secure way.
And then it would be automated
and it's simple and standard way.
So the vision that Vitalik Buterin who
was the main creator behind the theory
I'm head is to basically make the
internet into a giant computing mechanism
rather than mostly like an information
storage and retrieval mechanism,
make the Internet into a giant computer,
but making a really simple programming
language for scripting transactions among
different computers and different
parties on the Internet where you have
encryption and you have democratic
decision making and distributed storage of
information like programmed into
this, this world computer. Right?
And then that was a really cool idea.
And the,
and blockchain and solidity programming
language made it really easy to do that.
So it made it really easy to program
like distributed secure transaction and
computing systems on the Internet.
So I saw this, I thought,
well like now we finally have the tool
set that's needed to implement some of
the sources is very popular.
I mean,
I mean basically almost every ICO that
was done the last couple of years was
done on the ethereum blockchain. What's
an ICO? Initial coin offering. Okay.
So for Bitcoins,
for crypto currencies use
this technology offerings.
Right?
So what happened in the last couple of
years is a bunch of people realized you
could use this etherium programming
framework to create a new cryptocurrency
like a new artificial money and then you
could try to get people to use your new
artificial money for certain
types of Honi artificial coins.
Maybe more,
but I mean how many popular is bitcoin?
Bitcoin is bitcoin is by far the most
popular delirium is number two and there's
a bunch of others.
I mean how quick comparison like how
much bigger is bitcoin and ethereum?
I Dunno,
five factor factor of three to
five so maybe just a factor of two.
Now it's actually last year at theory
I'm almost took over bitcoin when bitcoin
are crashing. Yeah, yeah.
Now I him is back down.
It might be half or a
third of that for you,
the fluctuating value of these
things to my, to my mind,
creating artificial monies is one tiny
bit of the potential of what you could do
with the whole blockchain tool set it.
It happened to become popular initially,
right,
because it's where the money is,
right? I've been right. It is.
It is money and that's interesting
to people. But on the other hand,
what it's really about is
making the world's computer,
it's about scripting with a
simple programming language,
all sorts of transactions between people,
companies,
whatever, all sorts of exchanges
of information. So I'm,
it's about decentralized
voting mechanisms.
It's about Ai's being able to send data
and processing it for each other and,
and pay each other for their
transactions. So I'm in the, there's,
it's about automating supply chains and,
and shipping and ecommerce
so that there's, in essence,
you know,
just like computers and the Internet
started with a certain small set of
applications and then pervaded
almost everything, right?
It's the same way with
blockchain technology, like it
started with digital money,
but the core technology is going to
pervade almost everything because there's
almost no domain of human pursuit that
couldn't use like security through
cryptography, some sort of, you know,
participatory decision making and then
distributed storage of information. Right?
So,
and these things are also valuable for AI,
which is how I got into it in the first
place. I mean, if you're making a very,
very powerful AI that is going to,
you know,
gradually through the
practical value delivers,
he will grow up to be more and
more and more intelligent. I mean,
this AI should be able to engage a
large party of people and ais and
participatory decision making. They,
I should be able to store information,
you know,
when a widely distributed way and,
and AI certainly should be able to use,
you know,
security and encryption devalidate
who are the parties in involved in its
operation. And I mean, these
are the key things behind,
behind blockchain technology.
So I'm in the fact the
fact that blockchain began
with artificial currencies,
to me is a detail of history.
Just like the fact,
the fact that the Internet began as like
a nuclear early warning system, right?
It did. It's good for that,
but it's, as it happens,
it's also even better for
a lot of other things.